my relationship with Peter on was
definitely one of the most formative
ever that man his I was actually at a
working dinner with some people from the
open society institute George Soros's
organization and I was chatting with
them about this project that they're
working on with dialogue in the public
sphere and I was introducing myself as
having a religion studies background and
one of them said is Peter on still
teaching at Columbia because he shaped
like my undergraduate career there and I
got to say yes he is and he's a huge
influence on me as well so he is
prolific and his class really did even
though it's very much survey really did
suck me in to religion that was a big
formative class and I've never met a
single person who has taken that class
and not thought it was one of the
greatest experiences at Columbia
University and I know that it's dragged
a few people kicking and screaming with
me into the religion department as well
it should and the fact that I've been
able to go in just as a random student
from his hundred-person class and he
knew who I was he remembered my essays
because that man it's the extraordinary
effort of reading and grading all of
those essays like 400 essays a semester
on top of his work as a Dean that's
amazing that's sort of an inspirational
figure and somebody who's been able to
provide me with a lot of guidance
feedback and insight over the years but
other people who have had an influence
on me have not necessarily even been my
instructors there was a TA named humza
Stanton a while back who you know his
feedback on some my initial stuff in
that islam class was really important
guiding me along yl Halak who's over in
the massage department but teaches a lot
of things that are functionally religion
do count for the department he sort of
guided and prodded me into the African
side of things and his class on Islamic
law was one of those great mind-blowing
experiences and something that I was
really happy to engage with I think in
the end I have to say that if I can keep
listing these relationships but I've
never had a bad class in the religion
department I've had some that more
spectacular than others but I've never
had a bad class in the department and
I've never found a teacher in the
department who was not very engaged with
the student population which is vastly
different from what I found in many
other departments here